so we all know about make America great
again that's been a political slogan of
President Donald Trump but there's this
other slogan that is increasingly being
used by the president it's America first
and America first is a very very
different thing than make America great
again and we talked about this just a
little bit around the time of Donald
Trump's inauguration America first has a
really dark past connected to Nazism and
to white supremacy and to the KKK and
recently Trump's been using America
first as a slogan more and more rather
than the fabled make America great again
here's one tweet from Donald Trump from
just a couple of days ago where he said
I as president want people coming into
our country country capitalized why we
don't know who are going to help us
become strong and great again people
coming in through a system based on
merit no more lotteries lotteries also
capitalized hashtag America first as bad
as America first in this tweed is the
regularly atrocious grammar and sentence
sentence structure of Trump's tweets but
that's not the point of this story
that's nothing new
America first is this is not something
Trump even comes close to having
developed on his own right it has a very
long history and there was something
called the America first committee which
was formed I believe in 1940 early in
the 40s and it was anti-semitic it was
pro-fascist it was a pressure group that
didn't want the United States getting
involved in World War two partially
because they didn't believe that
preventing genocide against Jews was a
worthy cause that justified getting
involved in a military conflict and some
of the characters surrounding this
movement or people were aware of right
for example known anti-semite Charles
Lindbergh he became a huge advocate for
the America first mentality and this
became a calling card slogan of the KKK
we've got a couple of images in fact
that we're showing our television
audience you've got a KKK rally with a
cross burning in the back
and one sign that says America for
whites and another sign being held that
says America first also another picture
from some bigger March with a big KKK
sign saying America first one God one
country one flag and two of the people
that eventually became sort of
higher-ups in this America first
movement previously tried to stop Jews
from representing the United States in
the 1936 Olympics this is such a
political history that it even at one
point became a topic for dr. Seuss who
had a cartoon actually on yet four or
five at minimum cartoons related to
America first but we have one single
frame comic cartoon up on the screen for
our television audience so Donald Trump
is increasingly using and tweeting a dog
whistle that we know is connected to
both white supremacists and anti-semites
and that has been around for nearly a
century at this point but but but David
Trump's son-in-law is Jewish and Trump's
daughter Ivanka by conversion is Jewish
so how could Trump be anti-semitic this
is not about Donald Trump's beliefs for
all we know I'm not saying that this is
definitely likely but it's possible the
Donald Trump doesn't even really know
the meaning or the history of the phrase
but he's using it for one reason or
another and he's rallying in coalescing
white supremacists this is code two
white supremacists that Trump is their
guy it emboldened them as we've seen
them in Bouldin for the last year and
add this to the recent talking point
about more European and Norwegian
immigrants and fewer immigrants from
[ __ ] countries or [ __ ]
countries we don't even know at this
point which word it was whatever it is
that Trump thinks he's doing this is
appealing to white supremacists and
racists and remember that term I forget
if it's from The Simpsons where it was
like a fake slogan for Fox News not
racist but number one with racists or
something like that
it
ultimately doesn't matter whether Trump
knows the history of the America first
committee and that's why he's saying
this or whether he likes the sound of it
or whether one of his advisers has put
the idea of saying this into his head it
is a dog whistle to these groups no
matter what is in Trump's head when he
uses well I don't think most Trump
supporters are racist or more most
people who use the slogan are racist I
think they may just not understand the
history behind the term okay
I think that but let's say that that's
true at minimum it is definitely still
an appeal to the sort of most jingoistic
and destructively I guess they would
call it patriotic elements of society I
think that they would argue that the
term has been co-opted so now that it
means something that's anti-globalist
anti UN anti foreign aid right it's the
meaning by using it under Trump they
have taken the term back from the white
supremacists and the KKK or whatever
yeah maybe that's what they would say I
don't know but increasingly Donald Trump
is using that phrase and it's really
important for you to know the origins of
it